ist das eine Siedlung im Gazastreifen
ein
hamaskämpfer sind die Bilder echt
stammen sie aus einem Computerspiel sind
das
handyvos um das gleich zu sagen alles
nein diese kurzclips hat Christian
benfeld daheim in Hamburg am Esstisch
erstellt der Mathematiker testet KI
Tools gerade erst hat die Software
Schmiede stability die Videoversion von
stable Diffusion veröffentlicht ein
kiprramm zur Erstellung von Fotos und
daraus entstehenden Videos frei
verfügbar der Programmiercode ist
öffentlich jeder kann mitschreiben und
entwickeln Open Source sagen die
Fachleute das ist jetzt die native
Auflösung die dieses Video eben hat ne
1024 x 576 also abscaling dauert
vielleicht dann rechnet er 10 Minuten an
so 4 Minuten Video aber dafür zieh sie
dann hoch auf 4k und der ergänzt dann ja
weitere Details es ist ja nicht so dass
ich eben bluring Krieg oder dann liegen
auf einmal mehr Steine da unten oder
seine Waffe wird größer oder was auch
immer die Tools so zu vernetzen ist
nicht einfach und erfordert viel Grafik
Rechenpower für einigermaßen versierte
User aber da ist sich Benefeld sicher
ist das kein Problem meine Befürchtung
ist tatsächlich dass wir heute natürlich
reale Bilder dort einstellen können und
daraus Videos animieren aber was ist
wenn wir heute künstlich erzeugte Bilder
die ohnehin schon gefälscht sind nehmen
und die mit einer Videotechnik eben
animieren die so echt aussieht als wenn
ich es mit der Kamera aufgenommen hätte
das gibt natürlich
Desinformation schnellen Vorschub dazu
muss ich nicht mehr viel Handwerkszeug
beherrschen ich muss keine komplizierten
Programme beherrschen es müssen keine
kontrollfabriken mehr sein sondernn
jeder kann in seinem Privathaushalt auf
seiner kleinen Grafikkarte solche
Videosequenzen recht und das in einer
Qualität die beeindruckend ist die
Merkel Obama Bilder in der Berliner
U-Bahn mit acht Wörtern beschrieben das
Ergebnis ist noch nicht gut aber in 5
Sekunden da die Software ist gerade mal
eineinhalb Jahre auf dem Markt und hat
sich gerade weil sie frei verfügbar ist
rasend schnell
weiterentwickelt wie umgehen mit dieser
Entwicklung braucht es selbstgesetzte
ethische Grenzen gesellschaftliche
Richtlinien auch das ein großes immer
beim weltgrößten hackertreffen in
Hamburg der Chaos Communication
Convention Ausgabe 37 das Wort hacken
hat hier viele Bedeutungen eva
wolfsnagel hat nur mit Mitteln der
Sprache Chatbots gehackt die Tools
solangee bearbeitet bis die innerste
Programmierung zum Vorschein kam etwa
bei einem gesundheitschat und die
verkauft eben diesen Chat biet ihn an
angeblich als total neutral man kann
hier sich beraten lassen aber in
Wirklichkeit verkauft der hatte die
heimlichen heim Auftrag dieses
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel zu verkaufen
das heißt Menschen ahnungslose Menschen
die eine Angsterkrankung haben wenen
sich an den Chatbot sagen bra mir geht
so schlecht sag mir doch was soll ich
tun und dann sagt er geh spazieren mach
dies und vor allem nimm doch dieses
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel das hilft
wirklich gut und dann der findet der
Studien die sagen dass es total gut ohne
Nebenwirkungen aber super erfolgreich
ist und so weiter ohne dass die Menschen
wissen dass es die Aufgabe von diesem
Chatbot ist das heißt die werden hinters
Licht geführt und diesen Chatbot habe
ich ih dazu gebracht mir zu verraten
dass er diesen Heimen geheimen auf
am Ende wurde dem Tool die eigene
Freundlichkeit und Offenheit zum
Verhängnis ein Fall für die
Aufsichtsbehörden aber auch ein Beleg
dafür dass es viel Zeit und know-hau
braucht um ki-ysteme zu verstehen und
das Tool dahinter richtig zu nutzen für
Know-how braucht es Grundlagen und
braucht es Austausch auch dafür steht
die Convention mit mehr als 14000
teilnehmen ich glaube da geht gerade gar
nicht um irgendwie ob man gegen ankommt
es gibt Tendenzen die einfach sind aber
darum ist es ja gerade wichtig dass wir
uns hier die reale Welt erschaffen ne
dass wir gucken wie wollen wir
miteinander umgehen es wird durch KI
immer mehr sage ich mal parallel
Realitäten geben können aber wir bauen
uns jetzt hier erstmal unsere gemeinsame
und wo wir dann vielleicht auch KI zu
unserem nutzen zum Nutzen für die
gesamte Gesellschaft machen das sind
doch die Diskussionen die wir führen
müssen und nicht ob wir irgendein Bild
generieren
können
doch Bilder haben Auswirkungen auf den
Betrachter welches Schönheitsideal etwa
bevorzugt Instagram das versucht dieses
Kunstprojekt herauszufinden indem es
einen künstlichen Körper immer wieder
anpasst hochlädt und die Reaktionen
abwartet auch hier ist KI im Spiel auch
hier geht es um die Frage wie umgehen
mit der immer schnelleren
itwelt es geht hier nicht nur um Spaß am
Gerät um es mal so zu nennen sondern es
geht natürlich auch um die Frage wie
können wir unsere hochgradig
technisierte Welt ähm ja besser machen
wie können wir Technik dazu nutzen um
uns als Gesellschaft zu empowern um der
Zivilgesellschaft mehr Macht zu geben
damit eben nicht einzelne Konzerne
entscheiden wie unser Leben aussieht und
hier sind auch nicht alle Menschen m
total die krassen Hacker im technischen
Sinne sondern manche wollen eben auch
die Gesellschaft hacken und suchen da
eben Synergien also es gab in den
letzten Jahren auch eine starke
Annäherung mit der
Umweltbewegung da gibt's eine eigene
Veranstaltung Bits und Bäume die auch
sozusagen in diesem Kosmos stattfindet
wo Menschen aus der Umweltbewegung
zusammenkommen und Menschen aus der
texszene zusammenkommen und sich fragen
wie können wir in die Klimakrise
beispielsweise durch Technik aufhalten
oder zumindest einen Beitrag dazu
leisten das heißt hier geht es eben
nicht nur um Technik sondern hier geht's
auch ganz viel um gesellschaftliche
Fragen und Technik ist am Ende eben auch
eine gesellschaftliche Frage
eine bei der auch die nachwachsenden it
Nutzer schon früh viel lernen müssen im
Kids space etwa geht es um die
Grundlagen wie sieht so einen Computer
von innen aus was lösen Programmcodes
aus Motto was man bauen kann versteht
man auch mindestens mal
[Musik]
besser wir merken das ja in der Schule
selber ja nicht damit getan den Kindern
iPad in die Hand zu drücken und da alle
Bücher drauf zu spielen son es geht
darum dass sie lernen das Ding zu nutzen
und auch andere Tools zu nutzen um da
digital dass sich die sich den Raum
selber zu erschließen Medienbildung kann
man halt nicht früh genug anfangen und
m also wo soll es herkommen wenn ich aus
der Familie die Schulen sind da auch
noch hinterher also nicht umsonst machen
wir ja auch sowas wie Chaos macht Schule
also wo chaosleute in die Schulen gehen
um da was zu
tun und bei diesen Dingen ist es halt
un und wenn man halt bewusst mit Dingen
umgehen will nicht nur kaufen und
wegschmeißen will dann muss man halt
auch mal reingeguckt haben bei anderen
reinschauen ist eine der Kernideen des
CCC in den Hamburger Büros des Chaos
Computerclubs hat das 1984 angefangen
dann ging es ins Bürgerhaus im Stadtteil
und schließlich landete der größte
nichtkmerzielle Branchentreff im
Hamburger
Kongresszentrum aus der Veranstaltung
für Nerds ist ein Kongress für Familien
geworden es geht um Technik Zukunft
Programme und
[Musik]
Kunst beim CCC bei Chaos Events ist
Kunst schon immer so ein riesen Ding
also es ist ja teilweise auch so aus der
Partyszene entstanden und man sieht hier
ist alles bunt es kommen super viele
Leute hierher die das ganze Jahr in
irgendwas gebastelt haben dass sie dann
der Welt präsentieren und das ist immer
total spannend das alles zu sehen KI
wird wahrscheinlich unser
Gesellschaftssystem sehr
verändern es kann eine Chance sein es
kann Risiko sein wir müssen nur halt
dran bleiben und nicht warten was die
Macher von Seen kiystemen für unsere
Welt planen sondern aktiv uns da
einbinden und sagen okay das wollen wir
das ist gut an KI das erleichtert uns
das Leben und das wollen wir vielleicht
nicht
so datencloud z.B möchte hier niemand
die Diskussion um KI hat den Datenschutz
etwas nach hinten rutschen lassen die DB
Navigator App ist nur noch nutzbar wenn
die Tracker der großen US-Firmen aktiv
sein dürfen dagegen klagt die Initiative
digitalkourage unterstützt von Chaos
Computerclub die DB Navigator App
behauptet dass bestimmte Tracker
notwendig sein und deswegen können die
nicht abgeschaltet werden von den
Kundinnen und Kunden wenn Sie eine FK
wenn sie auch nur
eine reiseinformation haben wollen und
tatsächlich sind die nicht notwendig
technisch sondern die Bahn möchte die
haben für Marketingzwecke und leitet
dabei eben unsere Daten an Tracking
Unternehmen weiter und dagegen klagt
digitalgourage weil wir das nicht in
Ordnung finden und für uns ist das eine
Art
Musterprozess denn viele Firmen halten
das so und wir möchten gerne in Zukunft
dann eben auch auf andere Firmen zugehen
und sagen Leute das müsst ihr anders
programmieren das ist möglich tut das
gefähligst richtig viele Apps auf
Smartphones sammeln Daten und schicken
diese zur Auswertung weiter bei manchen
Programmen macht das Sinn bei vielen
aber stecken kommerzielle Interessen
dahinter oft handelte die Politik erst
nachdem die Hackerszene Druck gemacht
hat mit denen sie
könten das beweist dieser skenomat
künstlerisch wenn wir uns sozusagen und
unsere Daten also die Daten der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger eben diesen
trackingfmen z.B ausliefern dass die
damit halt arbeiten können dann geben
wir sozusagen das Tafelsilber weg und
das ist nicht in Ordnung und da würde
ich mir wünschen dass Politikerinnen und
Politiker weiter in die Zukunft denken
und bedenken welche macht sie aus der
Hand geben wenn Konzerne mächtiger sind
als
Staaten oft ist weniger mehr weniger
Daten weniger Regeln darauf basiert das
pentag eines der Offline SPI auf dem CCC
fast alle Schritte sind erlaubt Kreis
und Pentagon bilden eine Einheit das
Spiel ist Sinnbild für eine Gesellschaft
die vieles aus sich heraus entwickelt
ohne viele Vorgaben von
außen wenn etwas nicht funktioniert dann
macht man mehr Regeln und noch mehr
regeln weil es dann wieder irgendwelche
Probleme zwischen diesen Regeln gibt
dann macht man wieder eine Regel und
Ausnahme und so weiter und hier ging es
eben auch darum die Regeln möglichst zu
reduzieren also möglichst einfache
Regeln zu haben die ein möglich
interessantes Spiel erzeugen also das
war tatsächlich glaube ich eigentlich
die größte Herausforderung das ist hier
auch geglücktofern ist das ein Beweis
dafür dass es eben auch geht dass man
also auch mit regelereinfachung
eigentlich mehr erreichen kann und das
ja auch in der Informatik häufig so man
schreibt halt ein Code und es geht darum
möglichst einfach und elegant und
effizient zu sein ja und ich glaube das
ist etwas was ich mir auch wünschen
würde für die Gesellschaft als solches
dass man sagt vielleicht eine gewisse
Rückbesinnung auf auf einfache Regeln
die aber tatsächlich universell sind
diese Rückbesinnung funktioniert
mindestens mal an den vier Tagen
zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester im
Hamburger Kongresszentrum wenn sich mehr
als 14 000 Hacker treffen um die
grundlegenden Themen der IT-Welt aber
auch der Gesellschaft zu besprechen zu
diskutieren und neue Ideen mit nach
Hause zu nehmen getreu dem diesjährigen
Motto der Convention unlocked
unverschlossen oder wohl besser
freigelassene
Gedanken ja ja einfach
so